P
PLENTIFUL THREAT.
>> THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE COMMUNIST PARTY IN CHINA
HAS WRAPPED UP ITS WEEKLONG
NATIONAL CONGRESS'S WHICH XI
JINPING IS SAID TO BE NAMED ON
SUNDAY TWO THIRD TERM AS
GENERAL SECRETARY OF THE PARTY.
IT IS THE MOST POWERFUL
POSITION IN CHINA, BECAUSE THE
LEADER OF THE ONLY RULING PARTY
ALSO CONTROLS THE GOVERNMENT
AND THE MILITARY.
IN A SIGN OF HIS TIGHTENING
GRIP, AND MR. XI JINPING COULD
ALSO BE GIVEN A NEW TITLE.
LET'S BRING IN CNN'S STEVEN
JIANG.
STEVEN, TELL US, SO THE
CONGRESS JUST WRAPPED UP?
>> THERE IS ACTUALLY A BIT OF A
HIGH DRAMA, BY DOING THE
CLOSING STORES CEREMONY IN
VIDEOS AND IMAGES.
WE SAW FORMER CHINESE LEADERS
USING THAO, WHO IS MR. XI'S
PREDECESSOR GOT LEFT OUT OF THE
ROOM, ACCOMPANIED BY TWO MALE
STAFF MEMBERS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE CEREMONY.
NOW WHO WAS SEEN HAVING A BRIEF
CONVERSATION WITH A TWO MAN,
AND APPEARING TO BE RELUCTANTLY
LET OUT AND BEFORE THAT HE WAS
ALSO SEE TO HAVE A BRIEF CHAT
WITH JINPING, AND ON THE
SHOULDER OF THE COACHING.
NOW BECAUSE THE OPAQUE NATURE
OF CHINESE POLITICS, WE ARE NOT
CLEAR ABOUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THIS VERY SUPPLIES.
THIS SURPRISE MOMENT.
STATE MEDIA HAS NOT REPORTED
THIS AT ALL, AND AS WE START TO
TALK ABOUT THIS, THE CHINESE
CENTERS BLOCKED CNN'S SIGNAL
HERE IN CHINA.
BUT IT IS QUITE A IN UNEXPECTED
MOMENT IN THIS USUALLY HIGHLY
CHOREOGRAPHED EVENT.
OTHER THAN THIS MOMENT, IT
SEEMS THAT THINGS HAVE GONE
RELATIVELY SMOOTHLY FOR XI
JINPING ACCORDING TO HIS PLAN.
BECAUSE THE DELEGATES, THE 2300
DELEGATES HAVE SELECTED A NEW
CENTRAL COMMITTEE.
THAT IS NOMINALLY THE
COMMITTEE'S LEADERSHIP GROUP, I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE A GRAPHIC
TO SHOW THE POWERS OF PARTIES
HIERARCHY.
THIS GROUP IS NOW GOING TO MEET
FOR THE FIRST TIME ON SUNDAY,
AND THEN THEY ARE GOING TO
SELECT THE NEXT INNERMOST
CIRCLE OF POWER, THE 25 MEMBER
BUREAU, AND IS FROM THAT GROUP
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO FURTHER
SELECT THE SEVEN MEN GROUP.
ALWAYS MAN, NO WOMEN HAVE MADE
IT TO THAT GROUP.
THAT SEVEN MAN REALLY GOING TO
FORM THE TOP DECISION MAKING
BODY IN CHINA.
ANOTHER BREAK WITH RECENT
CONVENTION, SHE JINPING WHO
SITS A TOP OF EVERYTHING IS
GOING TO BE CONSIDERED --
HE IS THE ONE MAN WHOSE
DECISION MATTERS.
HE IS CALLING ALL THE SHOTS,
AND THAT IS WHY HE IS DOING THE
CLOSING CEREMONY.
ALL THE DELEGATES ARE DOING
QUOTE UNQUOTE VOTING
UNANIMOUSLY TO CHANGE THE
PARTIES CONSTITUTION TO CHANGE
HIS POSITION IN STATURE, AND
FURTHER ELIMINATE HIS
PHILOSOPHY BY ADDING SOME OF
HIS FAVORITE TERMS AND PHRASES
LIKE PROSPERITY, FIGHTING
SPIRIT, AND NOT TO MENTION THEY
HAVE ALSO APPROVE THAT LENGTHY
WORK REPORT THAT HE DID LAST
SUNDAY.
IF YOU NOTICE CLOSELY, THERE IS
SOME VERY CLEAR SIGNS THAT HE
IS GOING TO, THAT HE IS LIKELY
GOING TO CHANGE THE PARTIES TOP
PRIORITIES.
SHIFTING IT FROM ECONOMIC
GROWTH, WHICH HAS BEEN THE CASE
FOR DECADES, TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AND SOME ANALYSTS ARE WORRIED
THAT THAT IS A FURTHER SIGNAL
THAT HE MAY REALLOCATE SOURCES
TO PREPARE TO MOVE THE NATION
TO A LONG TE